Amy Chua author of world on fire one
sentence popped out of me out to me as I
read the book you say Americans are
unaware of the problem what problem well
the book is about
most Americans tend to assume that
markets and democracy naturally go
together
and the thesis of the book is that in
countries with what I call a market
dominant minority markets and democracy
are not mutually reinforcing because
markets and democracy basically benefit
different ethnic groups
so take Indonesia as a an illustration
free-market policies in the 1980s and
1990s led to a situation in which the
countries tiny 3% Chinese minority
controlled an astounding 70 percent of
the countries private economy the
introduction of democracy in 1998
produced a violent backlash 5,000 homes
and shops of ethnic Chinese were looted
and burned 2,000 people died 150 Chinese
women were raped the wealthiest Chinese
left the country along with some 40 to a
hundred billion dollars of ethnic
Chinese controlled capital plunging the
country into a crisis from which it has
not recovered so in countries with a
market dominant minority in Indonesia is
just one of many examples markets and
democracy benefit not just different
people or different classes but actually
different ethnic groups markets make the
resented minority richer and richer
while democracy increases the political
power of the poor frustrated indigenous
majority and the result is almost
invariably tremendous instability and
very often violence
define the term indigenous well I tend
to put indigenous in quotes because it's
a perception I mean there is a for
example the indigenous Indonesians are
the Prabhu me majority who felt that
they were there first and that the
ethnic Chinese are outsiders or invaders
now I put indigenous in quotes because
many of the Indonesian Chinese have
lived there for four generations
the same with Zimbabwe I mean the
indigenous black majority is indigenous
in a real sense but many of the white
Zimbabweans have lived there for again
for generations let me go back to your
term because it comes up throughout the
entire book market dominant minorities
yes one of the ones that surprised me
was the Lebanese in West Africa yes
explain that well actually everybody
from West Africa is familiar with this
so it's interesting that many Americans
including myself was not aware of this
the West African countries for example
Nigeria there are many local indigenous
disproportionally successful African
ethnic groups also for example the EBU
in Nigeria but most salient ly most
almost in virtually every West African
country there is a very small population
of Lebanese ethnic Lebanese again who
came over sometimes two or three
generations ago and they are essentially
the driving force in the link to global
capitalism they you know foreign
investors do all the deals with them and
they are extremely disproportionately
wealthy they typically in Sierra Leone
that I discuss a great length
until their rebels took over they
basically the Lebanese minority
essentially controlled the diamond
industry which was and that's that's
often true market dominant minorities
tend to control the most the country's
most valuable natural resources which is
another of the crown jewels which is
another reason that they their dominance
provokes such hatred and resentment you
came local with your discussion about
Koreans in Los Angeles yes explain the
market dominant minority in Los Angeles
being Korean well in general I asked the
question I talk about countries outside
the United States and one thing I say is
that the United States does not have a
market dominant minority at the national
level whatever one occasionally hears
about Koreans or Jews the United States
economy is not controlled by any ethnic
minority and I actually document that
look at the 10 wealthiest Americans Bill
Gates and the the other nine in the
Waltons yes the family none of them
belong to any identifiable ethnic group
however I then get more specific and I
say that actually if you look at
particular regions or areas in the
United States you do see echoes of the
same phenomenon and yes in Los Angeles
and many of our inner cities Korean
Americans are essentially in market
dominant ethnic minority visa vie the
much poorer and much more populous
african-american majorities around them
and it's actually very similar because
the there's a sense of them being
newcomers and outsiders that have come
in to take away something that's not
rightfully theirs because they they are
relative newcomers and the Los Angeles
Riots that I discuss in the more recent
instance in Brooklyn are very familiar
they follow a very similar pattern where
the poor majorities of these
neighborhoods are actually kind of
whipped up and stirred into anger by
demagogues I mean often politicians who
play on ethnic hatred for their own for
their own advantage where did you get
the title world on fire my publisher not
your idea not my idea
not my idea as an academic I don't think
I would have such a stark title my own
title I can t remember what it was but
it was long and boring why did they pick
this do you have any idea um I think
it's because my work originally started
off as you know academic articles even
my mother couldn't understand them and I
think they probably wanted to make
people more aware that it's not that I'm
not writing about distant phenomenon but
about events that really affect them
including I write about September 11th
also in the and the implications of all
this for America and your book is
endorsed by wild spectrum here of people
including strobe Talbott and Tom soul
how do you get you know that's a
divergent ideologue group there from one
side to the other
that's something I'm actually proud of I
I I think that I think that a lot of
people are very bored of the the debate
about globalization it's sort of going
nowhere and people are tired of it and I
don't even think it makes sense to talk
about the right and the left when it
comes to globalization so I I think that
both globalization's critics and
globalization's enthusiasts overlook
both make mistakes they both overlook
the ethnic dimensions of free-market
democracy so I feel that my book is
nonpartisan or at least along
traditional lines and and you know
neither left nor right in any meaningful
way and it's about a phenomenon the more
the idea of a market dominant ethnic
minority is for not entirely bad reasons
I think it's one that is almost taboo in
u.s. society you know the idea of
writing about an ethnic minority who
attend under free market conditions to
dominate economically the indigenous
majority around them so I think it's a
it's a it's a topic that's not been
addressed by either side so you know
it's not political that way I'm not by
the way I don't I don't think it should
be taboo because the idea of a market
dominant minority is not to be equated
with inherent entrepreneurialism I mean
I write about market dominant minorities
who owe their market dominance to
colonialism or apartheid like the whites
in South Africa has there the fact that
they are you know a very small portion
of the population 14% and have
historically controlled all of the best
land and all of the major conglomerates
you know owes principally to the fact
that they didn't let the majority vote
or live inhumane conditions for over a
century what do you do for a living
full-time I am a professor at the Yale
Law School are you a lawyer I yes
actually I went to law school I passed
the bar and I practiced for four years
on Wall Street at a at a major
international law firm where are you
from originally I am well I'm ethnic
Chinese I was born in Champaign Illinois
my parents
were both born in China but they left
China with their families for the
Philippines when they were young
children and most of my relatives are
still in the Philippines why did they
leave China for the Philippines for
economic reasons around 1936-37
they were from a poor province both
Fukien prabhu jam province it's no
longer so poor but many people from that
province at that time left they took a
boat and they headed straight and either
and many of them went to the Philippines
what years did they come over here well
it was my parents actually eloped to MIT
in 1961 I was born in 1962 and why
Champaign Illinois my father is also an
academic he they came over for advanced
degrees at MIT and then my father went
to complete his PhD at the University of
Illinois and my parents now live in in
Berkeley California what are they doing
now
my father is a UH mother probably
watching the show they are my parent my
father was a professor at Berkeley
teaches chaos theory and he travels a
lot chaos theory yes what's that it's
well he's an electrical engineer but he
works a lot in computers and mathematics
and I probably shouldn't try to explain
what chaos there it is so you grow up
for how many years did you live in
Champaign I lived for just a few years
then I spent eight years in Indiana
where my father taught at Purdue so my
three sisters and I lived in Indiana for
eight years and then we moved to
Berkeley California it's my hometown as
it turns out was just I didn't know that
you from up here so how long did you
live in life here eight years or seven
years and then what and then my father
received an offer to go to Berkeley so
we then moved to Berkeley California
where I spent another eight years did
you go to UC Berkeley no um that's what
my parents wanted me to go but I went to
Harvard where'd you get your law degree
Harvard
what was that like
um well which part of it going leaving
the family for a bit thing I mean here
you find your parents who started out in
Fujian Province in China and you end up
at one of the top universities in the
United States both undergraduate and law
degree hard uh come easy to you
well we always worked hard we always
worked hard how many are there in the
family three younger sisters I think in
some ways I think my immediate family
history of my immediate family is
probably a fairly typical immigrant
story my parents came over my father was
from a very wealthy family
but he left all that and my mother was
not she was from a poor intellectual
family so when they came over to the
United States they were penniless they
they really had no money you know no
heat in Boston so it was just very
natural we all knew we had to work hard
and we're all good students I can't
leave it without asking this subject
without asking about your three sisters
what are they doing one is a lawyer in
DC another is a MD PhD or actually a
postdoc at Harvard she's a a doctor and
uh and and a scientist and my youngest
sister lives with my parents and she is
10 years younger than I am she has Down
syndrome
she's the family favorite all right back
to the book for a moment world on fire
the idea for this came when when did you
what you know you've talking about
writing the articles wouldn't you know
he had a book and this was Doubleday
bought this I I actually never imagined
that it would be this kind of book I
started off just as an academic writing
academic la review articles about the
relationship between market reforms
democratic reforms and ethnic conflict
so I produced three ba review articles
and then I thought that I would perhaps
put it together many people suggested
suggested that I do so so I put together
proposal originally for Oxford
University Press
and you know it had
the proposal was three thousand pages
long and had two thousand footnotes and
through a series of coincidences a
friend suggested that perhaps I should
have an agent look at it and and have a
great agent and they suggested that
actually was interesting I they my agent
kept asking me is there anything
personal and this and this is only a
year and a half ago before I started
writing the book and I answering
honestly at the time I said no I know
there was nothing personal in this
because I think for me the whole
academic project has been precisely to D
personalize everything I'm writing about
complicated and controversial subject so
out for every fact I drop a footnote and
substantiate it with empirical evidence
and the last thing I've wanted is for it
to be subjective and personal but as
I've thought about it
the book has obviously changed I as
probably for every author it's of course
it's about what I know and and my own
background in assets you say personal
because you lead right off with a story
about your aunt
Leona yes tell us this story in 1994
this is I had just started as an
academic at as a professor at Duke and I
had started to write about these issues
already but I received a phone call from
my mother I was at Duke and she was in
California and she told me that my aunt
my father's twin sister Leona his name
is Leon had been murdered in the
Philippines
she was killed by her serve her
chauffeur and my aunt and my whole
family in the Philippines are part of
the very very economically dominant and
entrepreneurial 1% Chinese minority in
the Philippines and her chauffeur was
part of the largely impoverished much
more populous ethnic Filipino majority
and
so my mother told me about that what did
your aunt live she lived in by herself
and in a in a beautiful home in Manila
many of my relatives still live in
Manila and so how did you find out that
the chauffeur killed her and what were
the circumstances well there was
actually no dispute two maids
immediately confessed that they had
actually been accomplices I mean they it
was premeditated and a few minutes
before the murder
they testified that he was sharpening
the knife and and after the murder he
reported to them that their employer was
dead and the the police were notified
and sort of the usual things happened
but the murderer was never apprehended
and both of the maids were released and
part of this has to do with the fact
that first of all kidnapping of ethnic
Chinese in the Philippines is extremely
common extremely common and very rarely
are the the suspects apprehended and
part of this is I think because of the
intense resentment against the ethnic
Chinese and the fact that the police and
the security forces are are largely what
are all ethnic Filipino and they're not
that motivated in some ways I think
there's a lot of sympathy not
necessarily for the murder but but but
for the circumstances that would lead
people to do such things you say and the
book she was 58 at the time yes again
the chauffeur's never been caught no I
want police report what was the motive
the well it was interesting the
chauffeur apparently took some some
jewels some money but very stark for me
and this is probably why I opened the
book with this I looked at the police
report I was very frustrated both with
my family members in the Philippines and
and the police that nothing was
happening and I asked my uncle you know
were there any developments in the
murder case and and the answer was no
this is it's been closed it's uh this is
when I asked why so this is this is this
is the Philippines
not America so I actually got copies of
the police report and interestingly
under motive there was essentially just
one word and it was revenge which was
striking for me because it could have
been robbery it could have been
something else but it changed a lot
well that's that's an interesting
question I think revenge for my own view
is is it's a combination revenge for
feelings of humiliation and
powerlessness my many of the Chinese
Filipino families have many servants and
it's a very lopsided situation the
businesses are virtually all dominated
by ethnic Chinese along with a very
small sort of Spanish aristocratic class
all of the peasants in the Philippines
are Filipino all of all of the maids and
the servants in the chauffeurs are
Filipino and when foreign investors come
to do investment deals they deal with
the Chinese so I think it's full revenge
Rosa is a theme of the book I think it's
it's it's an act of revenge rooted in
tremendous feelings of anger and envy
and grievance and humiliation with about
60 million people in the Philippines yes
I think that's right and one percent of
them are Chinese yes what is it about
the Chinese that they succeed so well in
that country well this is a tricky
question that I that is not the main
focus of the book but many people ask me
this first first of all there it's very
complex and I definitely do not think it
is a genetic reason or necessarily even
a cultural reason groups can be market
dominant in one context and not in
another for example the Chinese in China
were market dormant for you know many
generations under Communist China as to
why the Chinese are so the Chinese
minorities of all Southeast Asia I mean
even right now Burma Malaysia not
Thailand I think part of it has to do
with the immigrant origins you know that
instilled a sense of hard work
um part of it has to do with family and
I guess cultural considerations but in
addition one thing I try to bring out in
the book a lot of it is part of it is
also favoritism so it's kind of circular
because you have this entrepreneurial
group that starts off and has
disproportionate entrepreneurial skills
and often in the case of Ferdinand
Marcos an indigenous leader will
actually go into cahoots with this
market dominant minority and then engage
in a symbiotic relationship where you
know I'll protect you I'll give you
these government franchises and licenses
you make a lot of money and you kick it
back to me so so I guess the answer is
that part of it is through part of the
reason for the extraordinary market
dominance of the Chinese is
entrepreneurialism hard work and I don't
know the reasons for that but on at the
same time in some cases also it's the
legacy of colonialism and crony
capitalism do I remember you saying that
the Malay and the Chinese do not
intermarry that's correct why not now
explain Malaysia what is it 15 million
people I can't remember politia is much
smaller than Indonesia I can't remember
I got a couple hundred million that's
right that's right but but why not the
end intermarriage between the Malay and
the Chinese the one important factor is
religion the Malays Malay majority in
Malaysia and the Indonesian majority in
Indonesia are principally Muslim and the
Chinese are not and so one professor a
friend of mine from Singapore was just
joking but he said it's the pork factor
that you know Muslims don't eat pork and
Chinese eat pork all the time and
therefore it's impossible to get along
and that's he was just being facetious
but I think that religion certainly has
played a role and an interesting counter
example is Thailand where this is the
Southeast Asian country where there has
been the most assimilation and even
intermarriage and I think
most people agree that one of the
factors is the fact that the tie our
Buddhists and not Muslim and this has
made assimilation between the ethnic
ties and the Chinese easier have you
been to that part of the world yes did
you ever meet this chauffeur by the way
when did you see your aunt in the
Philippines I yes I saw my aunt on many
occasions in the Philippines and I don't
know if I met this chauffeur I think not
but I I've often wondered that I've met
many chauffeurs I've often I've often
wondered if I had let me switch from
that part of the world into your trip to
La Paz Bolivia with your husband who you
Craig Jed Rubenfeld I believe is his
name he's Jewish and you bring that up
in relationship not to the La Paz trip
but to the situation in Russia yes why
before we go to La Paz tell us about the
oligarchs of Russia well I I start off
with a an anecdote I was I was actually
visiting at another University and I
have a colleague or a friend who was
writing about the Russian privatization
process he and some co-authors had been
very involved actually important
advisors to the government and he was
finishing up an article describing the
fiasco of the Russian privatization
process describing how the lack of kind
of careful planning and kind of laws
against you know anti-competitive
behavior laws against insider trading
how this had led to the looting and
chaos that ensued in Russia but
something about is his article struck me
so I went and asked my friend I said is
it possible that these seven oligarchs
and many of the principal players in the
privatization process is it possible
that they were Jewish and his reaction
was to immediately say no no I don't
think so
and I then said but it's interesting
ieave you if you look at their names and
any snap back you can't tell anything
from names and I was taken aback and I
felt bad but then actually just a few
months later - well one book came out
Chrystia Freeland book sale of century
in which she documented through four
ten interviews the profiles of the seven
oligarchs and in fact it turns out that
six of the seven people most commonly
call the oligarch so it came to control
you know most of Russia's natural
resources during the 90s were in fact
Jewish
what's an oligarch by the way well this
is the term that they use in Russia for
this small group of people who
controlled most of the natural resources
and then through their economic power
also exerted enormous political
influence
for example to use one of their words
guaranteeing yeltsin's reelection but
they also controlled the media and so
they poured huge amounts of money into
yeltsin's campaign and were rewarded for
that and you suggest this all came after
89 1989 yes follow the wall on the hole
change and glass notes and all that what
is it what's the impact though in that
country when I was reading and I was
thinking about this our own country that
in the early days there were a few that
had all the money yes same thing as they
get through they got onto democracy is
this working in Russia is democracy
working at all well this is tricky I
mean some of the oligarchs now you know
they actually their role models are the
Carnegie's they say that we know we we
used to be robber barons but now it's
time for us to a few of them have
actually turned to philanthropy and I
think that's a great thing it's a
complicated question whether what the
state of their democratic institutions
are right now wealth is still very
disproportionately concentrated in the
hands of a relatively small number is
there a percentage by the way like you
yes I at least sort of in the late 90s I
would say that the six or seven
oligarchs controlled I think fifty to
sixty percent of the natural resource
wealth I think I'm getting those numbers
right and if you look at fortune or
Forbes the list of the wealthiest people
in the world you'll see that you know
that includes three or four of these
Jewish oligarchs and but as to the state
of democracy I think it's um it's it's
not a you know there are different
analyses
what Putin is doing right now so what's
the reaction in Russia to the seven men
there was tremendous anti-semitism just
this the free speech and kind of instant
democratization led to lots of things
lots of positive things but they also
led to just a burst of demagogic
behavior and you know the Communist
Party leaders explicitly spewing
anti-semitism campaigning on
anti-semitic platforms there's a new
party that has just come into existence
that is explicitly organized around
taking back the wealth from the you know
greedy Jewish oligarchs so I think
that's one very negative side of the
transition the Paz Bolivia you and your
husband and two daughters yes two
daughters well the background to this is
I was a I taught a law and development
seminar a few years ago actually but
three or four years ago and I had an
excellent student from Bolivia I did not
know at the time that he was from the
elite classes it makes perfect sense now
if you think about it his name his well
I call him
Augusto Delgado not his real name no no
he's he's related to too many of the
presidents actually and I gave him that
option but he raised his hand in my
seminar and said he basically he was a
fantastic student and I loved him but he
basically challenged me he said you know
professor Chua my country is a direct
counter example to your thesis all these
bad things don't happen when you have
markets and democracy and a market
dominant minority in my country we it's
a very similar situation to the one you
described in Zimbabwe or Indonesia you
we have a very small light-skinned
minority about 3% of the population
control virtually everything they
control the economy politics culture all
the natural resources and are the
foreign investors partners and then we
have 65% of the population the majority
are impoverished in many cases
illiterate Aymara and Quechua
Amerindians
but what he said was in my country you
would never have an ethnic
based populist movement you would never
have an ethe no national event where
people politicians were campaigning on
anti quite campaigns and I asked him why
and he said because ethnicity has no
mobilizing power in my country it has to
do he was very smart and very self
conscious he said it has to do with a
bad history of racism but most Indians
are amerindians in my country would
rather identify themselves as peasants
than indios because that's a derogatory
term so the story is that two years
later this is just actually in 2001 he
emailed me from La Paz where he was a
very successful lawyer and political
commentator and he wrote to essentially
take back his words and he said you know
this is really the time to visit
it's amazing things are its
globalization and it's having
extraordinary effects on my country and
for the first time in recent history and
aymara a leader is actually generating
support among the indigenous populations
on an explicitly racist or ethnically
Indian based identity platform so saying
white should get out white should leave
the country the land belongs to the
Amara's and the Quecha was so and it was
it was very stark and it was also I
think a direct example of the collision
between free-market policies that
benefited the people like my students
and that well educated cosmopolitan
elite group and then a globalization and
democratization that not only empowers
the majority but also you know things
spread there had been an Indian movement
in Ecuador and through cell phones and
the radio and the television these kinds
of ethnic anger can spread too along
with capitalism and democracy so I
visited the pause of shortly after that
email just to see just to kind of see
for myself and how old are your little
girls at the time well now there are ten
and six at the time their names Sophia
and Louisa or Lulu and what did they
think of the trip down they they really
hate it they well la paz was fine the
pause was fine it was blue
beautiful eleven thousand feet yes as
soon as we got there the warnings were
all right everybody got headaches the
altitude it's it's stunningly beautiful
because it it's it's the city just Rises
out of a crater I've never seen anything
like it but it is very very high a lot
of radiation and and we all felt
enervated no energy and they felt the
same way everybody had headaches and but
then after La Paz where we were treated
beautifully we met physics exquisitely
well educated and thoughtful members of
the universities I gave some lectures
and that was very enjoyable but then we
set out for the rest of Bolivia on our
own and underestimated I think it's fair
to say the the level of under
development in that country then we were
stranded for days and places with no
heat and no sewage and at one point we
had to drive through a river to get to
the airport quite a raging river so they
weren't they it was interesting for them
to see by the way what your husband do
he's a also professor at Yale at Yale
you teach what at Yale I teach
international business transactions and
I submit a class called contracts and
then a seminar that changes this it's
currently it's called globalization and
law sometimes it's called markets
democracy and ethnic conflict it's where
I really get to know when learn from
students who are from many different
countries and many of my stories and and
infra much of my information actually
comes from students from different
countries mail and who was she
Malin is a well it's it's not her real
name but it's a it's a friend of mine
who was from mainland China grew up and
just left mainland China to marry a
native New Yorker and I she she and I
were at a Manhattan dinner party and
shortly after September 11th and this
was well her presence created a huge
argument that was very striking for me
so I reported in in one of my chapters
but she she asserted with great
confidence that 99% of the people in
China approved of and were happy about
the September 11th attacks and this
prompted a furious outcry among the
American guests I mean one guess I guess
properly asked ninety-nine percent I
mean what kind of pollster produced that
statistic just seemed a not quite right
and her response was you know let's not
get hung up on numbers face it Americans
are hated all over the world and deal
with it and then this conversation
deteriorated you say in that chapter
America today has become the world's
market dominant minority yes it goes
back to your theme about market dominant
minorities by the way is what's the
impact in your opinion of the market
dominant minority worldwide well market
dominant minorities first of all in the
book most of the book I the market
dominant minorities are right about our
within individual nations so you know
the whites in Zimbabwe or Namibia or
whites in Brazil or the Croatians in the
former Yugoslavia now the impact of them
it's it's it's interesting it's again it
there's a lot of subtlety here market
dominant minorities are often the
principal engines of economic growth in
our country this is certainly true of
the Chinese in Southeast Asia so so
their economic impact in some ways has
been tremendous they've generated
tremendous economic growth of the years
on the other hand their their presence
is a source of enormous instability
especially when you combine it with
rapid democratization because the
situation of having a small a situation
of where the rich people are not just
rich but they built they are viewed as
ethnic Outsiders stealing the nation's
wealth it's just incredibly
destabilizing so I actually think that
market dominant minorities are I say
that they're the Achilles heel of
free-market democracy in the non-western
world now to go back to your question
about the United States that's by
analogy where as you know in
to the book I write about individual
countries I suggest by analogy that at
the global level you see a very similar
phenomenon basically the United States
has become the world's market dominant
minority and the analogy has its limits
I mean obviously Americans are not an
ethnic group or a melting pot and nor is
there democracy at the global level on
the other hand you see very you see just
the same kinds of dynamics I mean the
Americans are 4% of the world's total
population and yet we wield just like
the Chinese in Indonesia or the Lebanese
in West Africa we wield just
astonishingly disproportionate economic
power relative to our numbers and from
China to the Middle East to France we
are perceived I think correctly is the
principal engines and principal
beneficiaries of global capitalism
you know we dominate global markets in
every respect technological financial
cultural and I think for this for our
extraordinary market dominance and our
seeming global invincibility we have
earned the envy and fear and deep
resentment of much of the rest of the
world
two statistics you report one of them
you see a lot of 1% I mean in this
country
Bill Gates his income is equal to 40% of
the lower income I thought it for some
of the public in this country makes the
same amount of money that he or is worth
the same amount of money that Bill Gates
one person is worth yes I put that in
because that maybe not now but at
various points in recent history Bill
Gates says you know controlled as much
as 40% of the rest of the American
population put together and what's very
interesting there is that Americans
don't hate bill gate Bill Gates and
they've never wanted to lynch him or
confiscate his assets in fact when the
government went after him most I think a
poll that I reports suggested that many
Americans just wanted him to be left
alone so he could go back and make money
and what's interesting is that that's a
very that's because the United States
does not have a market dominant minority
I think would be very different
and I actually propose this
as a thought experiment - for Americans
to imagine what it would be like if Bill
Gates and you know the ten other
wealthiest Americans were all pick an
ethnic group Arab or Chinese or Indian
and then further imagine that there were
that the the rest of the population the
majority was you know lived in
entrenched poverty and had experienced
no upward mobility for generations I
think that's the basic dynamic that
characterizes much of the developing
world I mean we have rags to riches
stories here you know if you ask some
some of a poor person in Arkansas
why they're Republican or like Bill
Gates and their answers they think that
their their son could be Bill Clinton or
or Bill Gates and that's just not the
case
in countries where the rich people were
all the wealthy people belong to a
different ethnic group a small aspect
you tell your own story when your
parents came here they had no money
that's right and so you give the
background of your own sisters and all
and and could you do what you've done as
a family in any other country well in
Southeast Asia that's exactly what the
Chinese have done so there yes the
Chinese were immigrants there and pretty
much became very dominant could you do
it in La Paz Bolivia um
well interestingly though there are the
Asian communities are fascinating
there's for example a very small but
very successful Japanese minority in
Peru now they're not market dominant
because I use a very strong definition
they don't control the economy but they
are disproportionately successful could
you do it in Sierra Leone I think not
although again I I think I understand
your your question I think the United
States is very unique in our the the
myth or the dream of upward mobility or
rags-to-riches is something that is I
think very unique in some ways
idiosyncratic to the United States I
mean even in our relatively prosperous
Western European allies that myth of
rags to riches or the dream of rags to
riches isn't doesn't have is not so
robust
I think people the United States really
believe in it
or a disproportionate number of
Americans really believe in it and I
think that's because of our history and
reality in some sense other statistics
there's six million billion people in
the world you say that 1% of the people
in the world control the same amount as
57% of the rest of the world in other
words there's a better way to say it
right right um yes so so at the world
level you see what is going on sort of
analogous to the what's happening within
nations and that is that global markets
have done a lot of good I mean I'm I'm
very in favor of global capitalism I
think in some ways that some form of
market generated growth is the only hope
for developing countries
but at the same time that you see an
explosion of growth and what you also
see is enormous inequalities of wealth
and this does have to do with a
phenomenon of market dominant minorities
sometimes all boats are lifted in other
words everybody in the nation gets
wealthier I think a lot of the
globalization debate kind of gets stuck
in that but all of the empirical
evidence that I have carefully looked at
from the World Bank and elsewhere show
that in many cases global markets do
lift all boats but the phenomenon of
market dominant minorities becomes very
important here because it's perception
that's important and you know if people
watching their televisions and looking
around them see that it seems like the
only the sudden new crop of billionaires
all seem to be Lebanese or or white or
ethnic Chinese they don't rejoice in
World Bank surveys that show that their
per capita income is increased by two
cents a day they you know so it's a it's
a double-edged sword I get the
impression that you're not really big on
Tom Friedman's theories of globalization
well I actually I'm a I'm a great
admirer of Thomas Friedman certainly we
are times columns yes I certainly read
his columns and I think he's just a very
thoughtful and erudite person especially
when it comes to the Middle East I I do
disagree with
some of his recommendations on the other
hand I think that he has changed his
views after September 11th so that our
views are much closer how do you change
well I think that in his book the Lexus
and the olive tree he presented a
picture in which markets and democracy
working hand in hand would transform the
world into you know peace-loving
prosperous nations and filled with kind
of happy Co citizens and then in the
process the quote not even subtext but
quite explicitly ethnic conflict and
religious extremism would be swept away
and I think if you look at the history
of the world in the last 20 years
just the opposite has happened after the
fall of the Berlin Wall we have seen you
know alongside the spread of markets and
democracy we've seen increasing ethnic
conflict the rise of militant Islam
confiscations calls for B
nationalization and two genocides of
magnitudes unprecedented since the Nazi
Holocaust so and I think that why I
argue that it's because whenever a
market dominant minority is present
markets and democracy are not mutually
reinforcing but on a collision course a
couple of other statistics 1 billion
people in the world make less than a
dollar a day yes and a total of 2
billion or half of the world's
population 6 billion people half the
world population which would be 3
billion earn less than $2 a day yes what
is that how do you how do we cope with
that I think that one of the great
challenges going forward is to find ways
to spread the benefits of global markets
to more than just a handful of market
dominant minorities you know 1% here 2%
here and there foreign investor partners
I
how you doing well I actually proposed I
don't think there are any easy solutions
but I do think you know again in some
ways learning from the example of the
United States I think the idea of stake
holding people rebel against markets and
voting
anti-market leaders when they feel that
they have no stake in the market they
feel like you know free markets benefit
a different ethnic uber or foreign
investors as well like Venezuela so they
the majority in free and fair elections
vote in a anti market anti us leader
whose policies of nationalization and
extremism you know would just stun
Americans people can't understand how
anyone could vote for that but he
campaigned Hugo Chavez a former
paratrooper swept to power in Venezuela
doing exactly what I predict which is
targeting the market dominant minority
in his country basically the 20% Mantuan
o--'s are the kind of whites that's in
quotations because this is a very
artificial term for people of European
features and European pretensions but he
targeted these oil controlling oligarchs
he called them and he campaigned on a
pro-poor Pro Pardo platform prada with
Pardo was the term for the brown-skinned
80% majority that lives beneath the
poverty line and he said you know
described Cuba as a sea of happiness he
attacked the United States
he attacked the oligarchs as a squealing
pigs and degenerates and they voted for
him and it was very ethnic it was
explicitly ethnic he he called himself
the Indian from barriness you know his
biographer focused on his Chinese
looking eyes and thick lips and people's
said we want to vote for somebody who
looks like us who's one of us and the
results I think have been disastrous go
back to that dinner party up in New York
with your friend male and who is not
really male and at somebody else what
was the what was the end of the evening
by the time the evening was over did you
agree that on why people hate us
no I I've been in many arguments about
this it's obviously especially after
said this was shortly after September
11th and emotions run very high
and I she I think represented the
position of many people the developing
world which is while not certainly not
necessarily condoning the attacks
she was nonetheless very sympathetic
towards the terrorists and understanding
of their motives for doing such a thing
and that particular conversation just
degenerated into charges of hypocrisy
against the United States and followed
by you know on the part of the American
guests their usual well who you know
what country isn't self-interested who
which country has done more for the rest
of the world in the United States you
know you think we have a claim as a
country that we've done more for the
rest of world than anybody else I
haven't calculated the the costs and
benefits but I think that yes I think
that I think that the United States has
done an enormous amount of good and and
that's one of the sort of the tragedies
of or the difficulties about market
dominant minorities this is the same
thing with the Chinese in Indonesia they
the 3% population there in the 80s were
really responsible for jump-starting
that economy and they brought generated
a huge amount of growth and yet the
perception among the pre boom majority
was that they were siphoning off the
wealth of the nation and they were
actually hated and scapegoated so I
think there was a parallel they're
picking up a quote out of the book
America is arrogant those are in quotes
now hegemonic and vapid ly materialistic
yeah right these are not my voice i i i
detail in the book i think that's when
speaking about anti Americanism it's
important to be very careful you know
the world is not a monolithic place and
there are many different forms of
anti-americanism so i've written about
you know there's what I call friendly
anti Americanism and I describe the
reactions to the United States and
countries like Canada or Great Britain
or Australia and this in some ways is
just kind of playful resentment I think
that's where the
a vapid ly materialistic quote comes
from and then I also discuss
anti-americanism in Europe which is I
think increasingly intense let me ask
you about this statement area there are
a Pauling number of Australian websites
filled with assertions that the United
States deserves the attacks of September
the 11th why Australia well this falls
into the category of friendly
anti-americanism actually after you know
I had a lot of research assistants kind
of trying to assess the situation and I
think a lot of Americans were surprised
again these are not people who
necessarily condoned the attacks but but
somehow understood it and and again you
know that the perception even in
countries like Australia or Great
Britain is that the United States is as
the sole superpower is just too powerful
or and and displays a lack of concern
for other other countries one figure
that again jumped out of your book 790
MacDonnell's in France I think it was
actually a number have close but yes
that's the statistic as of recently and
what is that I mean what what when you
when you think about your you know your
whole discussion about globalization and
all is that is it working I mean it well
I think I actually think that statistics
shows the love-hate relationship that is
a characteristic of many market dominant
the reactions towards many market domina
- you know on the one hand while people
are criticizing the United States many
people from the developing world are
just desperate to come here in fact a
friend of mine put it recently that the
view of Americans held by many people
many poor people in the developing world
is basically
Americans get out and take me with you
and I think that's a you know that's
part of what's happening now in France
it's a little bit different I think that
the the French elites are are concerned
that American culture is having a
disproportionate influence in France are
their market dominant minorities in any
of Europe European countries
presently no presently no like the
United States at the national level
none of the advanced Western European
countries or for that matter and I think
this is very interesting any of the East
Asian Tigers none of these countries
have a market dominant minority so in
some ways I think that's sort of very
telling that countries with a market
dominant minority have it much harder
that the tension between markets and
democracy which can be overcome in in
other context where ethnicity is not a
factor becomes catalyzed in countries
where the rich are outs of you does
ethnic Outsiders moving across the
Mediterranean you have 5.2 million Jews
in Israel you say and 220 million Arabs
in some 22 countries what what are you
seeing there about market at market
dominant minority
well the Middle East is a is a very it's
a tricky region and so much else is
going on there I mean obviously there
are religious factors questions of
colonialism and neocolonialism and land
claims so I am just observing one
pattern among many one dynamic and that
is that at sort of again at the regional
level actually within the individual
Arab States there are no market dominant
minority so again those are countries
without market dominant minorities but
at the at the regional level it's also
very stark that is Israeli Jews are kind
of a regional market dominant minority
they're just a tiny again 5.2 million
compared to over 221 million and Israel
is is a viewed as almost like a Western
Enclave I think I have the statistics in
there the per capita income I believe is
17,000 17,000 compared to I think 7,000
in Saudi Arabia and maybe 600 in Egypt
maybe 300 in Yemen so it's extremely I'm
not I wasn't aware of this until
recently that the I wasn't aware of the
enormous economic disparity
in that region well how could 5 million
people upset 220 million people the way
they do why are they so worried about
this little tiny piece of land with lots
of rocks when you've got so many others
over there and such they have a vast
amount of area compared to Israel well
again this is a huge topic and others
more expert have written about it I mean
there's a lot going on there with
foreign policy and oil and corrupt
repressive regimes one thing that I
think is happening is that the leaders
in many of the Arab states to deflect
criticism away from themselves are
deliberately fomenting and you know
they're deliberately fomenting anti
Israeli and anti-american sentiment
precisely to kind of target the
criticism elsewhere and throughout the
Middle East the Israeli Jews are viewed
a very common way of describing them is
as a Western colonizing force they're
actually often described as the last
wave of Western colonization and then
backed by the United States you talk
about Hollywood and television why
well that's these are more products of
globalization and but image are we
transmitting around the world well I
think that people have a distorted view
of the United States because what do
they see what is the United States for
the rest of the world they see our
president they see our supermodels they
see our multinationals and and that's
the slice of America that they see so
it's you know on the one hand Hollywood
creates this image of glamour this idea
that everybody here lives these lives of
indolence and luxury when in fact you
know many Americans are not like that
and worked very hard and so I do think
there's a that's part of the feelings of
envy and desire that global markets
perpetuate you say that Americans expect
the rest of the world to adopt democracy
overnight when we as a country didn't
yes this is one of the misunderstandings
that I frequently get about my book
people ask me if I'm you know against
school and
globalization and the answer is
definitely not I'm very much in favor of
globalization I don't know I think it'd
be futile to be against it
and they also ask whether I'm anti
markets or anti democracy and I am very
much in favor of promoting markets and
democracy globally both of them but
there are many different versions of
free-market democracy and I think that
we are exporting the wrong version in
fact I think we're where basically we've
been for the last 20 years promoting a
caricature a free-market democracy so -
on the market side there was no Western
nation today that has anything close to
a less a fair system I mean we have
progressive taxation and antitrust laws
and Social Security but for the last 20
years we've you know been urging poor
countries to adopt a kind of
bare-knuckled version of capitalism that
Europe and the u.s. abandoned long ago
and it's the same with democracy you
know for the last 20 years
I'm the American US government has been
urging the poor countries of the world
to hold elections to have you know
implement immediate universal suffrage
but yes in our own history was one in
which we disenfranchised the poor for
for four generations and more
importantly I mean I think that's out of
the question
you know property your exclusions from
the suffrage I'm not in favor of that
but I think more importantly democracy
in the West means much more than just
unrestrained majority rule which i think
is what we've been promoting I think
democracy is also about
constitutionalism and minority
protections and property protections
human rights I think a lot more thought
is needed than just shipping out ballot
boxes for elections which you don't
brought people like Milosevic
to power this is the cover of the book
it's called world on fire and our guest
has been Amy Chua Yale University law
professor thank you very much for
joining thank you for having me